Okay. Welcome everybody to this forum.
My name's Susan Galbraith. I head oncology research and development
at AstraZeneca, and I have the pleasure to be
introducing and chairing this forum.
And I'll introduce the other speakers just before they
come up. So we've had a
great day today, where we started with the
session this morning for those of you who made it in to Hall H first thing,
to hear about some of the advances in artificial
intelligence. The design of this forum, and forums are designed to be somewhat
provocative, is to have a debate about how we're actually using this
today in the real world across three
different environments. We've got representatives from
academia/biotech,
AI native biotech, and large
pharmaceutical company. That's me. Just to be clear.
So I hope that gives a spectrum of the interest in the
audience about what we're wanting to do.
So let me just start with my disclosures.
Obviously, I'm a full-time employee of AstraZeneca and
own stock in AstraZeneca.
So, at AstraZeneca, we are already using
AI tools across the full spectrum of our R&D
process, from target discovery, lead optimization, up
through phase one and phase two, all the way through to regulatory review.
What we haven't yet got, though, is a full end-to-end system.
We've got a whole variety of different AI tools that are used and deployed
across that process. And I'll give you some examples.
For example, in the discovery process for biologics,
with the advances that have been made in understanding and predicting protein
folding, we have models that are already helping us do
biologics design
from de novo, but also with optimizing and making
those faster. Similarly, we've already
embedded AI tools into the chemistry
process for our small molecule work.
And I'll give you some examples of how we're also using AI
in the translational space for tissue-based
diagnostics and also starting in the molecular imaging space.
And then finally, I'll talk a little bit about the development of multimodal
foundation models,
which you, again, if you went to the session this morning, you will have heard a
lot about in that context as well. And the hope
of how this can potentially be applied
to improve both early-phase decision making
and late-phase success rates in clinical trials.
That's the hope and the aspiration.
So,
how are we doing today? Let me go into some of these examples, and here's one
for
biologics. Now, the classic
process that we go through, in terms of discovery applied to both
small and large molecules, is once you've identified a target you want to
inhibit, you then have an element of design, and there's all sorts of
tools that are used for the design.
Then you want to make and test those designs
using standard assays, analyze, learn what needs to
be optimized, and then go around that cycle multiple times.
What you can see from the video on the right is in terms of how we're applying this
in a biologic space
is
wanting here to design a mini protein to bind to the dark gray part of the
binding site of a specific target of interest.
We start off with some random amino acids, which are
the orange spheres that you see on the
video. Random amino acids selected
to potentially bind to different parts of that target
binding site. And then the AI model is used to
help
both predict a structure that would potentially
fit into that binding site and then
design different sequences that will fold into that
apparent structure. And then they are rank ordered and
selected for subsequent testing.
So in this particular example, using the model, we had
264 designs that led to 45 binders, so that would be like
a 17%
success rate with the highest affinity of 28
nanomolar, and the whole process took just a month from
end to end. So, an example of it is possible to do this for
some subset of the targets that we're looking at, and it can
accelerate the process. So that's already
possible today.
And I think, just in an estimate of the speed enhancement, this can get
potentially just a third of the time of what you might expect for something that
was standard. So this is not science fiction
anymore. This is now today's reality, and I'm sure that lots of
other companies and
labs are also using these similar kinds of processes.
So now let me move to a small molecule example.
This is an actual lead discovery for an
intractable target. Obviously,
kind of redacted in terms of the target because that's confidential
information, but it is actually a real example.
Now, we have a
AI tool that's embedded into the
computers that all of our
chemists have access to, and it's a tool that we have published and
shared called Reinvent. And this particular target, you can
see again that we're starting with
a binding site that we're wanting to have
a good binder, too. But in the starting point that we've
got is
only got moderate potency, poor
clearance in the mouse model, and only moderate exposure.
So in this case, we're using the Reinvent to help with
affinity prediction and improvements against those
targetsAnd what you can see is that with the AI strategy,
generating novel compounds with a new interaction, we can
rapidly improve on the potency.
And as we go through that cycle iteratively, we've ended up
with
a potential molecule that has
target levels of potency, clearance, exposure, and tumor growth
inhibition. And in this particular example, again,
there's acceleration of what we would have as a non-AI
assisted standard process of around four months.
So that's
good to see.
So those are examples in the discovery space.
What about in the translational space? So we've shared data on this before.
We now have a lot of
targets that are targeting cell surface markers, antibody drug conjugates,
T-cell engagers, et cetera,
for which tissue biomarkers are used.
So we've developed this computational pathology scoring with an
algorithm that can first of all, identify on a
immunohistochemistry stained slide, which are the
cancer cells, and then also do subcellular segmentation, what's the
membrane, what's the nucleus, what's the cytoplasmic pixels, and do
that continuously and quantitatively.
And then identify feature classes of the images that you've got, which look at
the optical density in the individual pixels, perhaps in the membrane, but also in
the cytoplasm, but also can incorporate some spatial biology,
looking at spatial proximity scores, for example.
Those are the different imaging classes.
So, we then
change that on a data set, in this case, for a Trop-2 based
antibody drug conjugate, looking at-- And the feature that it pulled out was
the membrane to cytoplasm optical density
difference that seemed to be predictive and if you like, a surrogate measure of the
internalization rate of that antibody drug conjugate, in
this case, datupizumab duoxetecane.
So we're now in the process of getting prospective validation of that in a
phase three trial,
and that has the potential to be the world's first computational pathology
biomarker. But very rapidly, with the advent of a large
number of antibody drug conjugates
in similar tumor types, very rapidly, the challenge is
going to need to be a multiplex
approach here. And so what we're now doing is developing multi-cancer
cross indication QCS and in this case,
rather than
the fully supervised training of the previous QCS tool
that we had, which had individual pathologists doing
annotations on HS to represent
the ground truth, now we're using the Modela
foundation model that we've obtained, and in a
much shorter period of time, much more rapidly, we're able to then train to
actually get multiplex
output across settings. And the goal then is
to move that into an agentic AI-based
tool where these AI agents can use information not just
from the computational pathology, but from other modalities that might
also predict for patient benefit, including ctDNA,
proteomics, clinical records, multi-omics, and help
get from the domain specific models,
better tools for identifying patients.
This can potentially then be used for early phase decision
making and better identification of the patient
selection tools embedded into phase three trials prospectively, and
enabling some combinations. So that is the
goal and the future.
Now,
one example of this as well for another modality is molecular imaging.
And of course, the vision-based
foundation models have been developed over a long period of time and are working
very well.
One example is that in prostate cancer, actually, because tissue
biopsies are harder to obtain and less predictive, actually,
imaging tools are often used to identify patients, and this particularly for
the radioconjugate modalities, where the mantra
is that you
treat what you see and you see what you treat.
But in order to do that quantitatively, when you've got the extent of bony
metastases that this example shows here,
that is a lot of work from an individual manual piece.
And the current models have been just developed based on prediction
from simply baseline scans. What we're doing now is using both
baseline and follow-up scans, so you can actually track
the trajectory of each individual metastasis automatically identified
and tracked. And because you've got the longitudinal information in
terms of predicting longer term outcomes, it's much more predictive of those
outcomes than just something that looks just at the baseline.
And I think that principle of longitudinal information
embedded as part of the models that are used is a really important piece of
improving the prediction. And so the idea of this is it can predict
both spatial and temporal heterogeneity.
So, to move on to the multimodal foundation models that
then can be built off some of these bases.
What we're doing in collaboration with Tempus and Pathos is
building
the largest multimodal oncology foundation model, again,
taking longitudinal electronic healthcare record data,
lab values,
H&E
slides, images,
and genomics and/or transcriptomics where we have
it, in order to build this multimodal model that we hope will
ultimately enable us to better design the trials, better predict what
the control arm performance will be for the patient population
that is there, but also better select the patients who will respond.
And fundamentally, another key problem that we have in drug development
isIs making decisions based on the relatively small data
sets that we get from early-phase clinical trials.
And from this multimodal model, the hope is that we can build
digital twins that can effectively help amplify, if
you like, the
information and the data that you've got in those early-phase clinical trials, and
help make predictions about the right dose,
and the performance of what will ultimately be happening in
a much larger patient population in a more real-world setting in a Phase
III. The goal is to improve the success rates of those clinical
trials. And today, obviously, we still have too high a failure rate in
Phase III.
So, in terms of how this is working at AstraZeneca, I would just say already
we're embedding AI across
the system. And we started with the innovation ecosystem.
We can't do this all on our own. We are partnering with frontier AI
companies
to help us in many different aspects of this
build. We're also leveraging hyperscalers like AWS and
Domino to make sure we've got the adequate level of compute.
We're working with domain-specific specialized AI companies to help
in specific areas, partnering with key partners in academia, for
example, at Harvard and Stanford within the United States, but also
elsewhere. And then I think one thing that's really important is to make sure that
we're maintaining the dialogue with patient advocacy groups about how AI is going
to be used in the next version of clinical trials and how we
maintain the safeguards around that,
including adequate representation of
patient populations that are sometimes missed from some of the large clinical
trials.
So what we start with is these multimodal foundation models as
the model
layer.
Then we're
helping to build a solution layer, including agentic
AI, for example, for the computational pathology, and then
applying that in the specific use cases of which I've given you an example of,
which is the TRK2 NMR by QCS.
But that isn't enough. We have to also make sure that we
create the changes in the people process and culture.
We've got to make sure that we're enabling the training and AI
familiarity across a very large organization.
We don't just want to automate different parts of our process.
We want to think about what the design of the process might be with an
AI-first world. And we've got to make sure that we have the appropriate
culture
guidelines and guardrails in place to make sure that we're using this
effectively. So I hope that gives you some sense as an intro of how we're doing
and approaching this across a large pharmaceutical company.
And now I'd like to invite my
other speakers to come and give the context from their perspective.
So I can start with
Sigal
Kadish is going to give the next
talk. Sigal is a professor at
Harvard and also has been the co-founder of
Foghorn. So she has both the academic view in the lab
there and also a biotech view from the board
of
Foghorn about how these tools can be applied in that context.
So with that, thank you very much, and Sigal, over to you.
Great. Thank you very much, Susan, and beautiful work from Izzy.
It's really great to see this use of AI, and thank you so much
for including Josh and myself in this
exciting forum. I think you're going to hear
the wide distribution of our
motivations for including AI in the work from us, really
biology-inspired utility and operation in this AI
world, and certainly from Josh, a real deep dive look at how many of the engines
that we now use have actually been built,
including by all of his great work over the years.
So I thought I'd tell you a little bit about today some of the therapeutic
approaches and opportunities in chromatin and gene regulation that
have been informed by basic mechanisms that our group and others have uncovered in
this area and that we think are particularly ripe for the
not only inclusion but really adoption of AI
as we go forward. And as many of you know, our laboratory has had
a long-standing interest in understanding the structure and function of large,
multimeric, very heterogeneous ATP-dependent chromatin
remodeling complexes. So some of the work I'll share today is really just
from the lens and how we think about AI from the lens of studying these large
multi-component regulators.
So our laboratory is largely a basic science laboratory focused in biochemistry,
biophysics, increasingly 3D structural biology.
We really integrate in human genetics, which is really the inspiration behind
much of we do, and I'll go into that, as well as
epigenomic-based methods. And in parallel to that, I'm fortunate to
partner with and participate in groups that are intensely dedicated toward
translating discoveries in this area into hopefully meaningful therapeutics
for patients, which brings me to this requisite disclosure slide, most relevant of
which is that I'm the founder, as Susan mentioned, of Foghorn Therapeutics, and I
have the following other disclosures.
So
inside the nuclei of each one of our trillions of cells lies a vast,
highly interconnected network of factors that work together in concert
to orchestrate the overall architecture or topology of our genomes.
And we largely group these types of factors as DNA
or RNA modifiers, histone modifiers, or chromatin
remodeling complexes. And these work together to dictate
whether chromatin looks like this, largely in this off configuration, inaccessible
to transcriptional machinery, or in this nice open configuration shown here,
accessible for transcription factors and other transcription factor, that
transcriptional apparati to bind their target sequences
and largely enable active transcription.
And it's really the sequence positioning and timing of these factors
altogether and many more and many subclasses of each of these that
dictate very critical processes from human development to cellular
differentiation, lineage commitment, responses to external stimuli.
More and more, we really think these are the central hubs and integrators, if you
will, of cellular information, both intracellular information and in
responding to cues from outside cells.
And what we've really learned over the past decade, aided in large part to
large-scale genomic studies and sequencing studies and with the power of human
genetics, is that really any kind of defect in how this
runsrepresents a major cause or
contributing factor to human disease, and that's definitely the case in a number of
human cancers. So again, our laboratory is really focused on this
here, a simplified picture of this beast of a complex, which in mammalian cells is
actually pieced together from the products of
29 different genes into 11 to 15 or so subunit entities.
And that's made possible by the fact that there are
combinatorics that dictate the assembly.
These can actually be assembled into upwards of 1,000 different combinations in
even a given single cell, depending on the expression of different paralogs and so
on. They assemble into these three main forms, which over the years we've worked to
characterize. Canonical BAF complexes, pBAF complexes, ncBAF complexes,
just to show you that even within this family that has undergone quite an
extensive degree of evolution since its first naming in
yeast, we have these three main forms.
And there's also all these combinations are made possible
by mutually exclusive paralogs. That is one paralog or
another, never both, can fit the same structural pocket in the
complex. And you can see by just the repeating names of all the subunits I show you
on the left that there's several instances of that throughout this complex.
Now, the reason our lab is so extensively focused on these is that they are very
frequently mutated in human cancer, also in neurodevelopmental conditions is the
other place where these really emerge as very frequently disrupted
genes. And in addition to that, thanks to, again, genetics and
genomics-enabled technologies, for example, CRISPR
screening, we know that these are top dependencies and
vulnerabilities in a wide range of human cancers, which has really nominated
these as top targets for therapeutic inhibition and caused these to
jump to the spotlight of attention upon the earlier days of
CRISPR and shRNA-based even screening.
So again, we study these because they're very frequently mutated.
This is actually the most frequently disrupted entity,
second only to p53 across all of human cancer.
And in addition to their roles in a number of adult and common cancers,
as shown on the left, where they tally to 20% of these cancers, these are
also drivers of many rare cancers.
You can see here that actually many of these hit the 100% line or
come darn close to hitting that 100% line, providing very strong support for an
initiating role of some of the defects in these genes.
And actually, many of these disorders that I show you on the x-axis here
are pediatric malignancies, which is why I actually find my home department at
Dana-Farber in pediatric oncology.
We've learned over the years that different kinds of mutations can cause
subcomplexes to shift around. The stoichiometry or abundance of different types of
members of this family can shift, which underlie many of the gene
regulatory patterns in these diseases.
And we know also that certain paralogs, if one member or another is lost,
these cancer cells become uniquely dependent on the remaining paralog.
And that has nominated
SMARCA2, for example, as a top target in SMARCA4 mutant lung cancer.
That's being pursued by FogHorn and other companies.
ERBB1A mutant cancers with ERBB1B selective inhibition as
a tall and longstanding goal in the field.
These are just some of these examples.
So all of this is really the genetics have really been the inspiration behind much
of the data as input data that we've gotten in this field.
And the early days, exactly right when we were actually starting the lab,
these synthetic lethalities and mutations motivated us to really get a full
picture, biochemically and then increasingly at amino acid resolution
and with systems-based approaches. What's the composition?
How are these modularly organized? How do they come together?
What are all the possibilities for how they can combine?
To try to understand the 3D structure and topology.
This picture I show you here is now based on the 3D structure, but it's something
we now take for granted. But of course, just even five, six years ago, we didn't
have that picture. We would draw them as PowerPoint bubbles, never knowing exactly
which subunit touches which, never knowing which ones even interface with
chromatin. So really, this field has emerged and come a long way,
thanks to the work of many labs throughout the world.
Not only structure, but also lack thereof.
So lack of structure or putative lack of structure with intrinsically disordered
regions, which actually comprise over half of the molecular weight of this two
megadalton complex. So there's a lot of work to be done to understand these
sequences we don't yet fully understand and the functional relevance of what they
do.
We know that there are both direct as well as allosteric mechanisms of
modulating remodeling activities.
So how these complexes actually do their job on nucleosome
substrates. You can see they grip nucleosomes like a carpenter C-clamp,
and they ratchet these DNA nucleosome contacts.
Sometimes a single residue mutation at the very bottom of the complex actually can
come back around because of the allosteric effects to affect remodeling activity.
And otherwise, there are also pockets right within the catalytic pocket that
can affect remodeling activity. We've had a longstanding interest in understanding
how these complexes get where they need to go.
What is the navigation system along two meters of DNA?
How do they have these sequence-based and non-sequence-based cues for their
targeting?
And of course, all of this has motivated specialized efforts to
identify small molecule inhibitors that can target relevant human
complexes. Not necessarily just domains isolated from different
components here, but the actual full complexes as they act
in native mammalian chromatin. And of course, looking at
these as monotherapies as well as in combinations in oncology is the goal.
So really, we take all of these areas, and we've been increasingly inputting them
into AI-based strategies for integration, prediction, and also
network-based analyses. And this spans really the work we do on the
protein biochemistry and protein structure, all the way to the work we do
that is more genomic-centered. How to understand where these complexes
target, how they act, how much accessibility can they generate, and how much
transcriptional activity can be rendered by these
various combinations. So the outputs of this over the past
maybe even just year or so of really increasing our leveraging of
AI-based tools has been to develop new AI-powered models,
already using theThe frameworks that have been developed by,
say, TriDiscovery and many other alpha fold bolts and so on,
for both protein and gene regulatory questions to inform and
rationalize and provide really a foundation for how we
interpret the amassing and still increasingly amassing genetics
from high throughput screening as well as just cancer genetics from essentially now
every individual that comes through a major cancer center to provide
constraints as well, or guardrails, if you will, for AI-based predictions.
This is becoming increasingly important, particularly in small molecule discovery.
And again, taking all those outputs and using these to actually revise
our inputs and going back in this circular fashion to
revise and also further curate existing data sets,
the input data, the constraints that are actually needed to get a proper model
that can then be used for, say, in silico drug discovery.
And to reassess often targets their interactions
and opportunities that may have previously been obscured in the
data for cancer cell selectivity.
Again, I'll just tell you three quick little vignettes as to how we've done this.
We've had, again, a question as to how these get to where they need to go on
chromatin.
This has been beautifully worked out by a very talented postdoc in the lab
very recently. Sid Jain. He's actually here in the audience, and he just won an ACR
award for this work. This is really how we've explored how very
specialized factors, transcription factors, of which there are over 1,600
mammalian TFs, how these interact with a very specialized domain I'll tell you
about in a second, to actually guide the positioning and targeting of these
complexes on chromatin. How these complexes interact with features, this
seemingly endless universe of the histone code with multiple
post-translational modifications, variants, mutations, and so on.
How do these remodelers read and respond to that very vast,
also seemingly endless,
landscape? And finally, how do we interpret and
inform the functions and the roles of these
intrinsically disordered regions and their roles both in cancer and in our
normal cells and tissues? And so I'll just give you a couple of quick vignettes.
So this was the work on this very specialized domain.
We named this domain the SWIFT domain for switch-nit, immunoglobulin fold.
It looks like an immunoglobulin fold for transcription factor interactions, which
is really this out-pouching you can see of the complex.
It sort of spans this outward-facing module here.
And we used Alphafold 3 to actually predict where along, in this case,
one TF, a transcription factor called PU.1, also called SPI1,
where along that transcription factor TAD can this
TF interact with this structured hydrophobic pocket and domain?
We got these three products from probability mapping by Alphafold 3.
We then tested these, and you can see these three regions really
enriching on just a simple pull-down assay to really validate whether this was
truly binding in this allovalent, multiple binding sites on the TAD, binding
a single site on the SWIFT domain. We performed hydrogen-deuterium exchange
experiments where we can, of course, evaluate binding sites by looking for
protection in these assays. And excitingly, we see the exact same
residues that were pulled down by these peptide pull-down
experiments and predicted correctly by Alphafold
3-based modeling. So this was really exciting to show these two regions.
And this is broadly important because across all of human cancers, this is now
taking over 1,000 different cancer cell lines, and again, using a computational
approach to just predict how often is a member of
the complex that contains this SWIFT domain, and there are actually
three paralogs. I told you about this diversity in these paralogs.
There's three, SMARCD1, D2, and D3. They all have the SWIFT domain.
They're all slightly different. And if you look at fitness correlations, which is a
great way to understand genes that may function similarly
across the diversity of many, in this case, we have the privilege to
look at over 1,000 cancer cell lines.
You can see many of these are top codependencies.
Dependent on the complex was explaining how these are dependent on these
complexes, in some cases targeted by ATPase inhibitors, which
summarily wipe out the activity
of these remodelers. And here we see very specialized interactions actually that
are upholding
those cancer types. So we're excited about that.
We've also, again, looked at how these interact with different types of landscapes
on chromatin. So just all I want you to take from this complicated radar plot is
that different types of complexes in this family interact differently
with different types of nucleosomes decorated with different types of histone
modifications. You can see some really dial up the activity, others really
dial down the activity. Just as a sanity check, the places where these complexes
grip onto nucleosomes, which are called the acidic patches, any kind of
disruption in that acidic patch, you see a very big blue
area of density there. The remodeling activity is substantially
decreased. But it's amazing that even just along one histone tail, you see some
residues that if
acetylated, for example, really dial up the activity and just a few neighboring
residues down, those can drop the activity.
This gives you just a sense across one histone tail for the extensive
heterogeneity and degree of diversity we have interactions on chromatin.
And this is exciting to us because it's pointed toward very specific now
complex and even module-specific
strategies for inhibition. Rather than, again, summarily inhibiting the
entire engine across our human cells and tissues, really
specialized targeting interfaces that may be more amenable
to selective drug discovery efforts.
And finally, I'll leave you with the fact this is the structure of the endogenous
complex that we resolved several years ago.
You can see it's incomplete in parts, and actually, part of that is because we
use endogenously purified material for this.
This was not using recombinant complexes.
This was all endogenously purified from human cells.
You can just see the extensive amount of density that's unassigned
in these structures, which is lackluster for the structural aficionados.
But for us, it was actually a motivating factor to understand and try
to start developing studies that could help us inform what are the roles
of these putatively unstructuredor just disordered
low complexity regions of the complex, of which there are many.
You can see some of these total out-pouchings of the complex that have no described
function. Here's just an example of how bad this is, and here's how bad the
prediction is by AlphaFold. This is a complete set of spaghetti.
The majority of this 250 kilodalton subunit is totally not
solved and is very low complexity and is an IDR.
All that's solved is the part that actually inserts itself into the complex.
That's the only structured domain shown in blue.
This is 66% disordered, pretty bad, and it accounts for a
third of all the disorder of this entire complex.
So we thought that was a good bet. You can also see just how much we have to do
this work, because look at how many mutations, single
residue mutations are in cancer and in neurodevelopmental conditions in these
ARID1A and ARID1B proteins. You can just see how much these are smattered
throughout these IDRs that are
incredibly disordered.
But there's a significant burden of mutations across cancers and neurodevelopmental
conditions that motivated us to explore this.
So we did that, and computationally, we've been able to now take the entire set of
IDRs across this one remodeler and diverse remodeler
context and actually assign different clusters of features,
grammar features, amino acid sequence grammars, and analyze
these across the subunits of this complex
for the entire complex. And you can see that there are-- The ones on the left are
those that are hallmark to ARID1A and 1B that I showed you in the previous slide.
But look at how many other enrichments there are of different
types of features of amino acids and grammars.
We did this work with Rohit Pappu's group at Wash U.
You can see also if we look at the entire proteome,
these complexes in particular are very highly enriched for
"exceptional grammars," meaning those that stand out by orders of
magnitude when compared to every other IDR encoded
by the entire mammalian proteome.
You can see many of these are top-ranked features,
again, underscoring likely their
functional significance, which we have active efforts to try to understand,
especially for these paralogs here that again
remain top drug targets for the industry.
So all of this, I hope I've
motivated you and helped consider that this area in
particular is very ripe for AI-based identification of the proper targets
using the patterns from mechanisms like those that I described.
Is a target really one protein, or is it often a target should be
considered multiple proteins, at least two proteins coming together,
perhaps also in a different cellular context that allows increasing selectivity
for those cancer cells? This is definitely ripe in many of these interfaces for in
silico discovery of small molecule modulators, not only inhibitors,
for these specialized interactions.
And this has been a tall order in the chromatin and epigenetics
field, which has been overall for drug discovery, very challenging
because many of these regulators, these BAF complexes included, are broadly
commissioned throughout our healthy normal cells and tissues and for a
myriad of processes, from activating transcription, repressing
transcription, to
changing chromatin topology overall.
And so this is an opportunity if we can increasingly understand these interactions
and definitely guided by AI and in some cases
discovered by AI,
we have the opportunity for selective reprogramming and changing these
broadly commissioned machinery into opportunities for
cancer cell selective medicines.
So with that, I'll just thank the members of the lab.
There are many over the years that did this culmination of work.
The three stories I told you were led by Sidhant Jain,
the TF work. AJ Patil did the work on the IDRs.
Nazar Moshtaelier did the work on
the targeting with histones. Matthew King also did the work on the IDR.
So I'm thankful to you, Susan, for this opportunity to share some of our
biology and hopefully some motivation for what you're about to hear about in this
next exciting talk, and I thank all of you for your attention.
Thank you.
Thanks very much, Sagar. And now I'd like to introduce Josh Meyer,
who is leading the Chai Discovery, an AI
native discovery, a very different flavor of biotech.
And hope what you're going to help show is this how you design
discovery entirely differently, starting with the tools
and help provide those tools to the rest of the
ecosystem that's hoping to develop novel medicines.
So with that, Josh, over to you.
Thanks so much for hosting us, Susan, and great to be here today.
As Susan was saying, Chai Discovery is an AI lab.
We're building a computer-aided design suite for molecules, so really trying
to build these tools in order to accelerate the discovery of new medicines.
My background is a bit of a dual on the biology and AI side.
I was at the Broad Institute but really started my career on the early team at
OpenAI. Realized that if language models could speak English and French, why
couldn't they speak DNA and protein?
So we actually did a lot of the early work on this space at Facebook of all places,
where we trained some of the first transformer language models for protein
sequences. And it's been pretty incredible to see over the past couple of
years this technology has really reached an inflection point where you can really
start now using these tools in order to discover new medicines.
So I'll talk a bit about that today and how the field has evolved.
So first of all, the real reason why we exist and what we're aiming for
is this really big, ambitious goal of someday being able to design
antibody drug candidates directly on the computer that are ready for IND-enabling
studies. There's a lot that has to go right in order to reach that vision.
So we can break this down into a couple of other still ambitious challenges,
but maybe a little bit more tractable in the next few years.
So the first one is we need to output designs that can actually bind the drug
targets efficiently and without the need for library-based screens.
We ideally want to be able to take an epitope on a protein and then be able to
generate an antibody that can bind that with high success rates.
You can actually see on this animation here, these are real trajectories from our
diffusion models at Chai, where the model is placing these atoms in 3D space
and then trying to come up with an antibody that binds a given part on the
targetThe second challenge is even if you can discover a binder, there's
a big difference between a binder and a drug.
So the molecules that come out of the models need to have the drug developability
properties that you'd look for when building a therapeutic.
And then lastly, even if we can do the two of these things, we want our
molecules to be able to have therapeutic functions.
So for example, we want specificity to certain cancer mutations, or we'd like
receptor agonism. This starts to get us now into a territory of problems that
are pretty difficult to go after with traditional methods.
But if we can bring all these challenges together, then the outcome could be
drug-like antibodies to hard targets with atomic precision.
And I'll talk more about what that looks like in a few slides.
So first of all, just a bit of background, and what did the space even look like a
year ago. All of this work on being able to do antibody design with high success
rates and all that is quite new. If we look back at where the field was just a year
ago, we could barely design simple mini-proteins on the computer.
And if you look at it in an analogy of what we're doing on the computer versus what
we're doing today, we think of de novo design as some kind of computational
parallel immunization, where we're specifying a target for the model, and then the
model's trying to come out with a protein sequence that fits that.
So a lot of the work in this field over the past few years has really taken more of
a structural perspective, a protein folding perspective on this.
And a first step towards being able to do something like this is we need to be able
to understand not even just what simple proteins look like, but entire complexes.
So if you look at what's happened in this field over the past few years, at first,
you started to see really nice success rates for mini-proteins.
So Sujan showed some of this work, for instance, where we started about two
years ago or so to see high success rates on designing mini-proteins on the
computer. And you can see how this has evolved.
If you look at the Rosetta-based methods, we had usually less than a 1% success
rate. But then as you started to bring deep learning filters into it, the success
rates went up. And then eventually, fully end-to-end AI solutions, so ones that
used AI both for designing the molecules and then for filtering them out, were
performing really well. But we didn't see those same success rates happening in
antibody world. So if you look at what was happening in parallel for antibody
design, the success rates were still about 0.1% for the state-of-the-art methods.
And this is literally the state of the art one year ago.
And we hypothesized that a big reason for this was that the
protein-folding models weren't working well enough.
If you tried to put antibody antigen sequences into AlphaFold, for
instance, you would get a pretty poor prediction out of it.
So that was where we first started with the company.
And we were excited to see that with our models, we were able to really get a step
change improvement in antibody antigen structure prediction.
Most of this is actually driven by the underlying algorithm.
So it turns out that there is actually a lot of data that's even out there that's
not being utilized, and then new model architectures that we had to come up with.
But we're able to go from about a 10% success rate on this problem
to something that's now approaching 50% of cases being predicted with high
accuracy. The benchmark here, we're looking at fraction of cases on new
sequences that haven't been seen before.
What is the fraction of cases where we're getting a prediction that's within
experimental error? So it's exciting to see that we are making a
lot of headway on this problem, and that's what gave us the motivation to now set
our sights on de novo antibody design.
So that takes us to the first challenge.
Can we actually generate molecules efficiently now, the same way
that we saw it for mini-proteins? And in order to assess this, we set up a
big company-wide challenge. We tried to design proteins against over 50
targets, and
notably, we only tested no more than 20 molecules for each one of these proteins.
So the task was if we were really going to be able to get this technology to work,
it needed to be generalizable. So these are actually all targets that are different
than what the model had seen during training.
And we also needed the model to work with high success rates.
So we don't want to go screen a library for each of these.
We wanted to see if the model could do it on its first shot with no more than 20
designs. And it was really exciting to see when the data came back from the lab
that this worked for about half of the tested targets.
We were able to find a binder for each of them, testing no more than 20 designs for
each. This is data that we published back in June.
And the models have actually come a long way since then, so it's looking even
better now.
And it was really exciting just to compare this to where the field was at before.
Usually, when you're doing big science, you're trying to push for an
order-of-magnitude improvement on a task, and it was pretty exciting to see that by
bringing these next-generation models in, we really took two orders of magnitude
leap here. So, really going from that 0.1% success rate to
something that was now over 10%.
So we can generate binders to targets, but are those binders actually going to be
useful for things like drug discovery?
That's the next question that we started to go into.
So the first thing that we did is we took designs, and we just ran some
computational filters. What does the humanness look like for these designs?
Do they have liability sites? Do they have hydrophobic patches?
And the results looked pretty good.
The two main things to look at here are on the left, you have approved mAbs, and
all the way on the right, you have the Chi designs.
So the humanness actually looks pretty similar to fully human antibodies.
We prompt the model with human frameworks, and the model's actually been trained
that if you see a human framework, you need human CDRs.
So it's exciting to see that show up.
When we moved into the lab, we characterized the binders for a bunch of different
developability properties. We looked at yield and expression,
stability, viscosity, self-interaction, specificity,
and we used filters from a paper that
Adam Ma wrote a couple of years ago. The reference is Jain et al. 2017.
And they basically have a couple of different thresholds that you'd look for when
assessing the developability properties of molecules.
So you can see that over here. The green section for those first four
properties, those are the ones from the Adam Ma paper, and we find zero-shot right
out of the model. The sequences, for the most part, are already respecting those
constraints. So you see good thermal stability, good polyreactivity, good
self-interaction, hydrophobicity.
And then for some of the manufacturability problems like expression, purity, and
aggregation, you're also seeing pretty good results.
And again, this is right out of the model.
The model's never seen these targets before.
And on the first pass of generating sequences, you're already seeing molecules that
look pretty similar to molecules that have gone through the
clinic.So, the last
challenge that we wanted to address is can we actually go after some of these
harder therapeutic challenges? And in order to enable that, we wanted
to check whether the models could actually operate with atomic precision.
So if you're going to build an antagonist versus an agonist, for example, it's
going to be very important to hit the right epitope, to be able to hit the specific
residues. And the question was, with these new protein-folding models that we're
developing and design models, if we prospectively take those predictions and then
go test them with cryo-EM, for instance, how close are the predictions
to reality? And it turns out that they're quite close.
So you can see here five examples that we looked at.
And what we're showing here at the RMSD is the global RMSD
between the design and then what we actually found by cryo-EM.
If you go look at the interface, they're nearly perfect as well.
And the CDR loops were what was personally most striking to me.
If you just see the overlay in gray, the ground truth versus the
color and the predictions, it's nailing those loops almost perfectly.
This was personally very gratifying because years ago when I started to work
on this, from more of an AI perspective, everyone said the CDR loops are going to
be impossible to model. That's the really hard part here.
There's a lot of conformational flexibility, and it's pretty exciting to see just
how far the models have come on a problem like this.
So now that we have atomic precision, we can move towards this third challenge,
which is trying to achieve therapeutic functions.
So the first one we looked at was GPCRs.
So GPCR signaling is obviously very important, but it has unique challenges
for antibody discovery. There's minimal surface-accessible area to bind,
so you need to get something that's outside the cell membrane.
And then the conformation can also change when things will bind to it.
So trying to get something in an active versus inactive state, an agonist or an
antagonist, can be tricky.
So we designed antibodies to six GPCR targets.
For half of them, we tried to design things where the pocket was in an agonist
state, and then for the other half, we tried just to design binders to the
extracellular loop. And these models are prompted with a
specific hotspot. So what is the residue where you would like the antibody to bind?
So you can see on the left an example with CCR8, where we are
actually trying to have that VHH basically snake
in to the target here and try to achieve some
agonism. What was really cool is the solution that the model came up with.
This is, I'll show you data in a moment. This actually was shown to be an agonist.
If you look at the natural agonist for CCR8, which is shown in black over there,
the model's never seen that agonist before, but it's actually come up with a pretty
similar solution, this little aromatic ring that is interacting with the same
residues. So it's really interesting to see that the model has designed an antibody
that is sort of mimicking how this GPCR performs in that native state.
So let's turn to the data. The first thing that was interesting was that there were
surprisingly a small number of designs that we needed to discover those GPCR
agonists. So the first three targets are the ones that we targeted in an
orthosteric state, and we were trying to find agonists.
So these models have really high success rates, even for these hard problems.
So you can see for CCR8, we tested only 10 molecules.
Half of them were binding, and one of them showed signaling.
And then you see this also for CXCR4, CXCR6, and then the ones on the
bottom are targets that we tried to hit the extracellular loop and were also
successful.
A second challenging target class that we looked at is peptide MHC.
So this is not a case where the conformational dynamics are as
tricky, but selectivity is going to be really important over here.
So one of the things we've built into our model is not just an ability to choose a
specific epitope, but also to show the model either additional
homologs. So let's say for cross-reactivity or selectivity.
So you can tell the model, "I want to hit this target, but I really don't want to
hit this other target." So the challenge here is for peptide MHC
antibodies, you want this to be specific to a point of a single amino acid mutant.
With cancer, as we know, with a single amino acid mutant, that's what you might see
in this setting. So we want to bind the cancer form,
but avoid the healthy form.
So here's a structure prediction of one of the designs that was
specific to KRAS G12V.
If you look on the top right, we're showing the data of binding the KRAS
G12V mutant, but fortunately, the antibody was able to
avoid the healthy KRAS wild type. We also found that if we keep the
peptide the same and just change the MHC, you also abolish binding.
So it does seem specific to this peptide and this MHC.
Probably in follow-up work, we would just go take a whole boatload of other
peptides if you apply this for a real program.
But so far, this looks pretty promising.
And if you look at what the model came up with, so we gave it this task.
Again, it needs to be specific to this peptide. What did it come up with?
If you zoom in here on that G12V mutant, the model has actually found a
way for those CDR loops to actually interact specifically with that
valine. And this is probably the reason why we end up getting the specificity over
here.
So taking this all together, it's pretty exciting just to see where the field has
gone in the past year. Just a year ago, again, we could barely design simple
mini-proteins on the computer. You'd get things with like nanomolar affinities out
of the models. And we've now moved to a regime where we can design full-length
monoclonal antibodies with high affinities and high developability.
And we're now able to go after some of these really challenging problem for
therapeutics. There's a lot more room to go from here.
Again, our goal is to build molecules that are ready for IND-enabling studies.
There's a lot to figure out for how can the models better understand biology.
The hit rates for these models I showed you before, they're double-digit percent,
but they're not 100% yet.
We think that we've seen a scaling law here, where as we drive more compute and
more data into the models, they keep getting better.
So we're continuing to work on that and drive this forward, and hopefully one day
have a computer-aided design suite where, again, we can get drug candidates right
out of the model. Thank you.
Okay. Thank you. All right. Thanks very much. That was a great talk.
So I think you've got the spectrum of how we're applying this now.
So let's move to the discussion, and I encourage people to come up to the
microphones. But I'll start with a couple of questions.
So one question, and it's interesting, is when you're
designing-an organization
with AI in mind,
it might be a different construct than the traditional organization
of a biotech. So can you just give us some insight, Josh,
into the split of different roles in Chai
Discovery and how you might compare that to a more traditional
biotech? Are there different roles? Are there different people?
What are the skill sets?
Yeah. It's a great question. It's been really interesting to figure this out.
I worked in, actually, a biotech company before starting Chai, and the way that
we build the teams is, in fact, very different.
So one of the things here is that the technology moves so quickly.
Literally, you can see model improvements on a weekly basis.
We're always trying new things with the models and learning new things.
At the same time, though, it's also very important to be rigorous.
I think it's really cultural elements that are important here.
When things are moving so quickly, it's also very easy to drink your own Kool-Aid.
Not everyone is following all the right information.
So we've tried to build a culture of a lot of rigor and transparency internally.
If things don't work, we're very ambitious about it.
We want to get to 100% success rates with these models, but we also know we're not
there today, and we recognize that.
In terms of the people that we bring on,
we really have three main categories.
We have the AI researchers, so these are people who you would find
similar folks like that in the OpenAIs and Anthropic's of the world.
So they're building the core models.
You then have people who are actually building product experiences, so that's an
important thing as well, especially as there's more and more ways to prompt the
model. Think about that peptide MHC example.
It can be very easy to design something that's not actually specific to the immune
just because you prompted the model incorrectly.
So that's something unique about this field, and we do a lot of work even on the
software product. I didn't show any of that in the talk, but that's really
important. And the third, of course, is the science.
So when you have models that work this well, we need a smaller number of
people to do that work. But they actually need to have more context, and they need
to be really bright. So this is where we've brought in people to the company like
Andy Yong, who was at Genentech and Pfizer for 20 years and built his own drug
discovery company before. You've got people like Nathan, who are just like
prodigies at Harvard, finished his PhD when he's 22, and just very native to both
AI and drug discovery.
So it's been very cool to figure out all these organizational dynamics.
So if you just look at the split,
do you have
some percentage of the split of AI engineers versus
protein engineers, for example?
It's probably about a third, a third, a third between those groups.
One of the other things, too, that's unique about us is the company's actually only
two years old. So all this work we've had to figure out on that timeline, which
means we didn't have the time to go and build out a massive laboratory.
So instead, we work with over a dozen experimental partners.
So that means that the folks who are running all of those assays are not actually
situated in the company. I think there's more people doing experiments for Chai
than work full-time for the company right now, even.
So if you count it in that way, it's still a lot more on the biology side.
But overall, when you're doing things with AI, actually, each
person, I think, just has so much more agency with what they can do.
That's great. So Sugandha, if I turn that to you, how are you taking
both your academic lab and
Foghorn and thinking about the new skills that
you need to be applying? How is that going?
Yeah, I was thinking even as you were answering this question about the
organizational dynamics within the company, it's so different in an academic lab.
We have people using AI who are pure biochemists and
these platforms have gotten to the stage where now pure biochemists and those who
have never touched AI before are able to do it.
And of course, we also have for, especially when there's added constraints and
modeling needing to be done, then we see that it's often those with
computational skills and experience in machine learning, AI, and so on
doing that. But increasingly, we see this integration, and I think that's been,
for us, one of the most enabling, that we've seen people that-- One
of the advantages of an academic lab, certainly of our lab, I think, is diversity.
We have diversity of thinking and diversity of goals.
There are people in the lab that their goal is to identify a small molecule for a
given target. The other goals are to widely understand how all the different
compositions do different things, and how can we use systems-based
approaches to be able to do that.
As I highlighted in the talk, one of the key goals of our lab
is really to identify, down to protein-protein interactions,
the domains that are most responsible for given activities of this
very complex and heterogeneous complex.
A nice example of that is what I described with this TF binding platform, which
originally was discovered as a single TF binding platform, but again, using these
patterns of biology enabled by this, we were able to identify
that a multitude of human TFs actually engage there in
slightly different ways. And this is, again, now where we're leveraging and
doubling down on the AI-based
guidance to start to pull out the patterns
that tell us what features of an IDR in TFA are different
than that in TFB that dictate binding to one SWIF domain or another within this
complex, or a different interface altogether.
On other sides of what we do, we can now take and leverage some of these
interfaces, and use AI-based platforms, whether it's Bolts or
others, to start to in silico
model and discover small molecules or other agents,
peptides, whatever, that can actually engage with those
interfaces. We think the power-- And I remember actually when
you did this big collaboration with Eli Lilly, one of the first, which was really
exciting, and it's awesome. One of the things that was commented on both
sides was just that this is the optimal combination of
these brand new suites of approaches from Chai Discovery, but is
also enabled and requiring the partnership of deep expertise in a given
biologic domain, therefore antibodies,
and
domain expertise, as well as a suite of assay systems and a platform,
essentially, for the biologic interrogation.
And I think that more and more, that type of partnership is what we see as
absolutely critical. And so
whether it's a big pharma, smaller biotech
collaboration, or academics biotech or academics pharma collaborations, I think
the need for the biology doesn't go away.
Okay, thank you. Sorry, there's a question over here, I think.
Yeah.
First of all, thanks for
two wonderful presentations. So I have a question.
Very amazed by the results by Tri Discovery, and
amazing to get atomic level binders.
So I'm an antibody discovery
and protein engineer
area. So I'm curious to know, when you
first find binders to your target,
do
you expose the model to other protein other than your target as well?
Because when we have antibody involved in the body, it's
actually the negative selection actually that a lot of times happens at first to
avoid autoreactivity. So the binding
or not binding to other targets probably one of the challenging thing,
and that's actually a lot of time can derail a therapeutic down the
line and have very costly
mistakes. So I would like to hear your thoughts on that.
Great question. Thanks.
Yeah, great question. So the answer is, we do.
So I gave the p10 MHC example in the talk, where there you're prompting with, for
example, things that you don't want the model to bind to.
You can also do something where you're putting in an entire complex.
So I didn't talk about this in the presentation, but one of the
challenges that we look at is sometimes trying to hit...
I'll give TNF-alpha as an example.
This is something there is obviously a lot of antibodies that have been raised
against it. But I think still the Chai model is the only one that's been able to
generate binders against that target.
And one of the reasons there is you're trying to hit, at least in the way people
set up this task, is you're trying to hit this
highly polar
region between two subunits of the homotrimer in TNF-alpha.
So there's cases like this as well, where there's actually a whole complex that you
want to go after. Other things that we're excited about are, let's say
there's an agonist or you want to create some kind of
activity, that might trigger something downstream.
So one of the reasons why we've invested in building really good protein folding
models at Chai is to start to understand some of these biology questions later on.
So just think about where this goes in the long term.
We're still far away from 100% success rates on protein folding.
But imagine if you would get there, there would be tremendous opportunities to
explore things like that. And I think before you get to 100% globally, you'll
probably get, I don't know, maybe 80, 90% plus on maybe certain sub-problems there.
And that will enable a lot of really interesting things even on the target
discovery side. So I think the questions you're talking about, that's really the
frontier, right? And we're not quite there yet.
But those are the kinds of problems that are really exciting to us from really from
an AI perspective.
Yes, thanks. These are great answers because it's amazing that it's able to
use these AI or modeling to target epitope, because a lot of
times you traditionally in vivo, in vitro approaches, the
epitope or the choice actually is very hard to get any binders.
So this is really amazing pushing the frontier of antibody discovery. Thank you.
Thank you. Question here.
Yeah, thanks. This is a really very inspiring session, and it's good to
see the real case of how we accelerate the drug
discovery phase. It's hard to speak of AI without
speaking the fundamental of data and data sharing,
especially in the clinical stage.
I'm just wondering what's your vision in
the data sharing or knowledge sharing across organization or
institution while we can still maintain the patient
privacy or proprietary boundary,
especially in the clinical stage?
Yeah, it's a great question.
So let me use the example of the multimodal foundation
model that we are building in collaboration with Tempus and Pathos.
Obviously, what Tempus have already created is a very
large, well clinically annotated data set that's
multimodal, all of which was done with the appropriate
informed
consent from the patients that are involved there.
So that's the first fundamental piece, which is you've got to make sure that
the
content for the
consent is appropriate, and then that's linked.
When we think about that kind of example within AstraZeneca as well,
obviously we've got a lot of data from clinical trials, and there's
various levels of informed consent that are associated with that.
Actually, that whole process used to be pretty
manual.
And what we're trying to do now is make sure that we've actually got something that
is
more readily searchable and verifiable in terms of the
electronic piece and linked to the patient samples so that we can save a
lot of time and effort in terms of doing that.
So I think the comment about the data foundations have got to be there is
absolutely key. So that's the first principle.
If we're able to then create a foundation model that's on a
large trained data set, you can then apply that and
fine-tune it on other specific data sets.
So it might be possible then through collaborations
to provide access to the core foundation model, which
then can be fine-tuned on different institutions' or
organizations' own data sets. And then it's a sort of, if
you like, it's a unique manifestation of the application from that process.
So that's the principle I think that can be
applied. I think there'll be multiple iterations of that
you can see. And you kind of already see it in the
large language model world. So not multimodal, but large language
model. With multiple iterations of the different models, people can use one or the
other, but there's lots then of different applications that each is then
applied to. I think the same will occur in the
multimodal foundation models that will come up throughout
medicine and the life sciences.
Also, you bring up a good point, not only for patient protection and data sharing
with respect to clinical data, but also how do we go about best
practices for data sharing for academic progress in
labs?
Obviously, we have genomics repositories, proteomics repositories that
we are required to, and we submit these data.
Also coding repositories. But increasingly,
we're using AI models and modifying certain aspects and inputs and
constraints and so on.
What's going to be the standard for reporting all of
that?And I think that that is important because we need other people to be able to
reproduce our findings.
And we need to make sure we're taking a step forward for the
academic and pharmaceutical biotech community against, on different
targets or for different goals, to be able to use what's reported in each paper.
Oftentimes, you just say, "We use Chai Discovery.
We use AlphaFold, we use..." But we have to have more detail than that, I think,
to really be able to push the field forward and ensure that we are
thoroughly
honoring the data-sharing policy.
Okay, so just one more question from me, first of all.
So we've talked about a lot of the advances and the exciting advances in
AI, but
where is AI not working at the moment?
What are the
key areas where the levels of predictions aren't where we need them to be?
And what's the proposed strategy for helping to
fill that gap? So you talked about the intrinsically disordered
domains,
for example.
I imagine that those are the places where there's less
good prediction, but I don't know if you can give us some examples.
I'll answer the question by setting up the problem, and I'll have Josh solve it
live for us.
So, definitely as you mentioned and as I highlighted,
so far, AI-based strategies
for prediction of function, prediction of potential structure,
prediction of interactions for those regions of proteins
that are deemed intrinsically disordered or low complexity
are, to date, still poor. Increasingly, we've tried
to take more of a amino acid
sequence grammar sort of, which is really a purely computational
approach and fitting into algorithms as to what sequence
features portend binding with X other proteins, and this is the
culmination of proteome-wide data, interaction data.
But where it fails also is even in trying to do that, and trying to
essentially a priori apply AI to inform these large
sequences, again, over 40% of the proteome.
So we still have a big problem here,
including many cancer therapeutic targets, and that's even enriched further in the
nucleus,
is exactly the input data.
How are we taking these full stretches of IDRs?
Are we taking proteomics data that was just collated from proteomics
databases where we don't have a control of the quality of how
we captured protein A and then asked what are all the other proteins that interact
with it somewhere? That's never reporting on direct interactions.
It's always reporting on around interactions.
Often when these kinds of studies are done at low stringency
or with
BioID, these kinds of approaches, you're looking for really the realm of proteins
around. That's useful, but I think we need better
quality data that can parse out direct from associative
interactions. And the higher quality of the data and the mass of
that data, the amount of that data being put into these models, I think
will ultimately reveal that actually the models can do it.
It's just that the input data was lackluster and in some cases,
faulty.
Maybe one other thing to build on that.
So of course, there's the data we're using for training the models.
But then there's actually then the prompts themselves.
Yeah.
And we've actually discovered some pretty surprising failure modes with these
models sometimes. I'll give you an example of some of the early work we did at
Chai. When we first started generating molecules, we had things that the model
predicted would bind with really high confidence, but they went to the lab and they
didn't bind. And we went back and looked at the predictions really carefully, and
we found sometimes that maybe the sequences were clashing with the membrane, or
maybe they were clashing with a glycan and things like that.
So it turns out that the model actually did exactly what we told it to do,
or at least we hypothesized that, but we just didn't tell it to do the right thing.
We didn't tell it, "Don't clash with the membrane," or, "Don't clash with the
glycan." We just didn't give that information to the model.
We see the same thing, by the way, happen in the rest of LLM world.
So I don't know how many programmers there are in the world, but if you use models
like Claude Code in order to write code, one of the things people are
doing these days is really innovating on the input harnesses.
So actually, even I should have said this before in setting up the organization, a
lot of
documentation we write at Chai and internal docs is actually written for AI agents
these days. We write probably more
internal documentation for agents than we do for our own scientists, because then
we can set an agent on the code base and we can say, "Go write some code," or, "Go
set up this antibody campaign," and it kind of knows what to do.
One of the funniest things we've seen there now is a big trend, is people prompt
Claude, and they say, when they're trying to write really long code bases, they'll
say, "Think like a caveman." And then the model ends up talking in
incomplete sentences, which actually spends fewer tokens and uses less compute
power for the same result. So we're trying to figure out the equivalence of that in
biology world, and part of that is like, don't bind the membrane or don't bind the
glycans, so the model doesn't waste compute power trying to discover binders that
are just never going to work in the lab.
Those are good examples. Question over here. Thanks.
Thank you very much.
David Favara, I'm an oncologist and GPCR structural
biologist from the MRC LMB in Cambridge, England.
Got a question, Josh, to you.
You may have mentioned it. I came in halfway through your talk, so apologies.
What is your model, your system, how does it take into
account affinity maturation or improvement of binding affinity?
And
does it also generate nanobodies as well?
And the other part of the question I wanted to ask was,
in terms of the success rates,
what are the differences in
binding
when you've tested out your purified
antibodies,
those generated from experimentally solved, like cryo-EM
crystallography structures versus
your in-house
AI LLM-based protein structure plus your
ChaiBinder program.
Yeah. Really interesting questions.
So there are a couple in there. So first, VHH, and VHVL, the model can generate
both. So some of those agonist examples are actually VHH because then it might be
easier to hit the orthosteric pocket.
In terms of affinity maturation. One of the
interesting things too is we don't even now think about the models as
generating a lead versus then doing affinity maturation
on it. Ideally, the model can just get you the molecule that you want, right?
If we're going to hit that big goal of a development candidate right out of the
model, then, of course, you need that to be baked in from the start.
So we're trying to build more controllable knobs that the model can do that in a
zero-shot way. What we've found is as the models have gotten better,
the need for affinity maturation has gone down.
So it's definitely not there for all targets.
But as the models have gotten better, when we ask the model, "Bind this target,"
it turns out as it understands the structure better, understands interactions
better, it just finds more ways for that antibody to hit the target.
And then when you look at the outputs, if you go run a 96 well plate, you'll just
see a whole diversity of affinity.
So there'll be some that are really good, there'll be some that are a little bit
worse, and then you can choose the one that makes most sense for your application.
And I think the last question then was about
success rates if you use basically a experimental structure versus a predicted
structure. So we don't see much of a difference, but there is a little bit of a
cheat there.
One of the things that we can do is the models have really good confidence metrics.
This is both when we design molecules, so we can test ahead.
The model can tell ahead of time whether it thinks the thing will work in the lab.
But we can also do that for an input prompt.
So if you take in, let's say, a GPCR sequence, right?
Where we don't know what the structure looks like,
there'll be a couple of challenges there.
First of all, are we getting it in the active state versus the inactive state?
So we've been developing some techniques to solve for either of them.
But then you also just might get out a structure that looks like a bunch of
spaghetti.
And the thing is, the model will know that ahead of time.
And we just won't use that as a prompt.
So the system can tell you ahead of time that it thinks that this target will work
and that this target won't work. And, the goal there is, before you go spend
all of your time and money testing something in the lab, let's just actually have a
good, calibrated success metric for that.
So that's something we've invested in a lot because one way to drive towards 100%
is to just skip over the stuff that's never going to work.
And of course, we want to grow the set of targets the model does work
for. And fortunately it seems to be working for quite a bit.
But, yeah, for targets where the protein folding model doesn't work, at least it
can tell us that ahead of time, and then we skip over those.
But in cases where it is confident, we find that the success rates are actually
pretty similar.
Okay. Thank you very much. I wish you lots of success.
Thank you.
Okay.
So the next question. All right. You said already that
we've made huge progress in the last year, and I think it is, you see
it throughout the meeting, the general progress in this field.
So I'm not asking you to predict 10 years.
I'm not even asking you to predict five years, but just a year from now, at
ACR 2027, how do you expect that things will have changed?
I think that first and foremost, and we already started to see this this
year, but it's really the earliest days.
I think that a
far greater percentage of overall talks and
posters and presentations here at this meeting will
have been fully informed by an
AI-based drug discovery approach.
For example, taking an AI-based approach to in silico
model an interaction and then ultimately identify binders,
inhibitors, modulators of that interaction, test them back in the lab
exactly as
Josh was mentioning, test them back in the lab and have success enough to be
able to report it
at a meeting like this. I think for multiple cancer targets,
especially those that have been sort of prosecuted by the biotech and
pharmaceutical industry for many, many years, these are exactly the ripe targets
that we have on the table, ourselves included, for trying to use a
culmination and multiple companies based technologies.
I think as a scientist we may ultimately
favor one or another, but for us we also thrive on the diversity that can come from
putting multiple models against one another or taking the collective products
of those together. I think more and more of that is-- so more presentations and
more
drug discovery based efforts that are now actually going toward and being optimized
toward clinical development.
And more times where multiple models and
multiple companies infrastructure and foundations have been used for the
discovery. That's what I would predict.
Okay, thanks.
Yeah, I fully agree with a lot of that.
I think one of the interesting things that our field has in AI, which
is pretty different than others, is it's very difficult to verify if these methods
work. This field has honestly been smoke and mirrors for a long
time. And I can say that because I've worked on it for a long time.
And if you look at something like image generation or asking ChatGPT to
write you an essay or Claude to write you some code, it's very easy just to look at
it and do a sanity check, are these looking good?
So image generation two, three years ago, you had these hazy images and there was
clearly progress that was being made, but clearly they were
not very good. And the field has come a long way since then.
I think in this field it trails a little bit because to build the conviction
that it's worth trying these methods, you really need a lot of evidence because
it's expensive to run these experiments and it takes time to get a readout.
And I think now that we've reached-- those results that I also showed you on the
slide are all very recent, right? So I think the field is now passing that
inflection point where many of us here are going to start adopting the methods to
a greater degree. And even though these results are here now,
it's going to take the next year for them to be deployed.
But I think a lot is going to happen over the next year.
And the progress of the models is not slowing down either.
It's actually only accelerating.
So we've reached this inflection point where the methods are now starting to be
deployed, and they're only going to get better.
So I think 2027 ACR will be really interesting, where you'll start to
see penetration of these methods with a lot of the work.
And then probably the year after is when we will see some crazy discoveries that
are now becoming possible because of AI.
Great. Thank you. There's another question over here.
Thanks
Thank you.
Really amazing presentations and also the scope for AI to change from this
call is amazing. My question,
borrowing from honorable chairperson,
you mentioned what kind of workforce is needed, but someone who
is entering into the industry or someone just entering
the... What kind of skill sets one should develop to the
point of, Ms. Seagal, that it's not going to be
AI-assisted, it's going to be AI integrated.
So from the core biologists, what kind of skill sets one should develop so
that they have an edge? At the same time, for the established professionals who
have doing traditional way, how they should be thinking and what they
should be augmenting to their skill set?
We should probably ask the professor first.
I was going to say ask the
technical details first. I think, again, for this community in here,
whether this is for diagnostics,
and for the development of medicines for various cancers, I still think
that
we can fall short if we're not careful about, A, input data
and ensuring that we're guiding it exactly to your point earlier, Josh,
about did we actually ask it to do the right thing and make sure you avoid
certain aspects of the biology. That requires, on the biologist side or
computational biologist side, or experimentalist in the lab, for us to
have a very deep familiarity with the biology.
And we can use these models and input data, but without the
right guardrails or constraints, or you call them another term, harnesses, was it?
Without that, we will repeatedly fail.
And we have already received the results of first round, second
round, in silico-based designs and in silico-based
experiments essentially with failure.
But upon a second round, we think we can do better by inputting more of
that information. And sometimes that level of depth comes
from many layers, actually. Not only the layer of how two
proteins or three proteins or how these complexes are configured on
chromatin, but also what they're doing, which genes are activated, which sites did
they actually go. And you have to put in multiple sources of data.
That's another thing that I think is not always easy.
There's two domains, well, there are more than two domains, but two domains that
are very frequently talked about in here.
There's the protein side of AI, and that's much of what you've done.
But there's also this wide space of AI-based
strategies to collate and
illuminate new mechanisms and targets out of reams
of genomics data. And what's missing, we find, because we work
on two sides of the spectrum, almost every paper from our lab is integrating
protein and biochemistry and structural biology and the AI on that side with also
the genomics and epigenomics and other types of gene regulatory
sequencing-based methods. What's missing often without our
manual integration of that is something that can actually take those two totally
different sets of input data and build that together.
That's something I'd like to see increasingly done.
And I think, again, that needs to be done with the lens of
domain expertise across both biology and AI.
The thing I can add to that too is, I think getting experience with using agents,
is really important.
If you look at some of the-- We see this first now with software engineering.
But if you look at some of the software engineers on our team, a good fraction of
their salary is actually now being spent just on tokens of
using language models. And the folks who are doing really well
have just found ways to leverage themselves in incredible ways, like having a dozen
agents running in parallel, writing different code for them, or our scientists
writing pretty thorough documentation for Claude or ChatGPT so that they
can use it to find interesting targets for case studies or choose the right
epitopes and things like that.
So I think there's a lot that you can leverage yourself these days and
it's not obvious how to do it. And actually, there's no playbook because the
models are evolving right in front of us.
And what you need is an open mind, and you need ambition, and you need to
just take your evenings and try things out and find things that work for you.
And I find different people in our company, they're using different tools, they're
using different playbooks, and obviously they share with one another.
So, building a group of folks who are also
experimenting and learning from them and sharing strategies is important because a
lot of this you won't even find on the internet yet.
Because you might have a new model that launched two weeks ago, and then people
have now figured out how to leverage it into their workflows.
But I think the folks who will create the most value in the next year as well will
be people who figure out how to leverage these resources and basically 10X their
productivity compared to folks who aren't adopting AI.
Yeah. So I think, just to add to that, I think the first thing is don't be
scared.
Yeah.
Be curious.
Okay? And
dive in and iterate. I
can assure you that
none of this existed when I went to medical school.
And so you got to be willing to
adopt and learn and iterate in the
group piece and try and understand the language.
I think one thing that's really interesting that's happening now is that the
agents are then being putting forward into teams.
And what we're having to learn to do is how do we train the teams to work well
together? It's remarkably similar to how you actually train teams of human
beings to work together and collaborate as well.
So you've got to have different roles and functions as specialists and an
orchestrator as well. So I think some of the
core philosophy of how we do science today is still going to be
inherent in how we do science going forward.
But learning to
question and iterate with the agentic tools that you're
setting up, I think will be-
YeahOkay. I'm curious, Josh, do you name the agents?
And can agents be fired? Do you fire agents from time to time?
"Bob's not doing his job over here." How does that work?
And do you reorg the agents, much like Susan's asking
here? These are now essentially functioning people to an extent.
Do you reorg the agents and, "Bob's not cooperating on Team A, we're going to put
him on Team C." How does this go?
No, I think we probably should, though, because naming convention for AI models is
actually very hard because things are iterating so quickly, right?
So you have a new model every week, how do you name them?
And then you have different variants.
I have the model that's good for this task or this one or that one.
But actually, the way that we structure this in our code base is you can write
documentation for different sub-agents, and then you often just name them by
what task they are doing. So maybe there's the epitope selection agent, right?
And then you're like, "Your job is to do this." And then you can tell another agent
who's orchestrating all of it that, "Your job is before you decide on this, make
sure you talk to the epitope selection agent and get its feedback."
Yeah.
And then the epitope agent-
Yeah
... is not allowed to change the epitope. It's only allowed to give feedback on it.
So this is where it gets into building all these harnesses for the models, and it's
similar for our molecular design models as well.
You might have your design model that's looking for that peptide-MHC binder.
It's allowed to ask the protein folding model what does this thing look like in
order to then figure out how to keep changing the molecule.
The protein folding model is not allowed to change the antibody sequence.
No.
It's only allowed to tell you what it looks like.
Yeah.
So these things go back and forth-
Yeah
... and they talk to one another. And this is, by the way, I think, then a new
trend in this space. A year or two ago, everyone was like, "One model to
rule them all," end to end and so forth.
And these actually, they might be technically the same model weights, but
by giving them different harnesses, they actually end up
operating in pretty different ways.
And then you can string these all together to get some pretty incredible
capabilities out of them.
Have you calculated what's the maximum back and forth
that one, two, three, four, or five different agents have
had the dialogue between one another?
And did you calculate whether is there a correlation in the quality of the output
product based on how many interactions they had, if you had to draw a
scatter plot of these interactions?
No, it's getting quite high, actually. Depends exactly how you define this, right?
What the definition is of talking to one another.
But, for the results that I was showing you over there, there are many, many calls
that go into the model. There was a question before about affinity maturation.
This is one example of it. Maybe you have a molecule that looks like it's binding,
and then the model's asking, "How can I actually improve this?" And this is where
you're iterating through many possibilities. And I don't know.
We don't call that affinity maturation because I don't think that's exactly what
the model is doing, but it might be a good way to intuit what these
models are doing.
Mm-hmm.
Find some solution, iterate on it to make it better.
Yeah.
So, it's quite high. And honestly, it's
increasing exponentially. So we also need better algorithms as a
result because the compute costs just go through the roof when this happens.
Okay. Final question, I think.
Yeah. So thanks for the really nice talks, and I have a question for Josh.
Actually, two questions. The first is, how do you see the
relatively importance of improving the sequence and structure
design versus improving the downstream filtering
criteria? Which one do you think contribute more for a higher
final hit rate? And the second question is, I know you focus
on AI-based protein structure prediction, protein
designs, but I'm wondering, do you think it's necessary to incorporate a
physics-based modeling into machine learning approaches?
Or do you think currently, the machine learning, based on the existing
structure, is already enough to generate a high enough success rate? Thanks.
Yeah. Great questions. And my answer might be a little unsatisfying because it's
basically all of them are important.
And this is one of the reasons why this space is moving so quickly right
now. There's honestly a lot of bottlenecks.
There's a lot of opportunities to improve.
And if you can find better scoring functions, or you can find better generative
models, these are all things that can work together to come up with a good
solution. And, now that we have these pieces really
working together and talking to one another, if you will,
it allows us to now parallel track work on each of them.
So we have people who are just pushing forward all of the things that you just
mentioned, and whenever you get a breakthrough on one of them, then the entire
system gets better. Another interesting thing is that the crosstalk between
these things also can be multiplicative.
So meaning, if you have a better filter, for instance, it
might actually allow your generative model to sample even more stuff.
So maybe now I can say, "Hey, let my generative model think 10 times longer, come
up with more candidate solutions." And now I have a good filter, or I have some
good physics modeling or whatever that I can pull out the best ones.
So, that's how all these things work together, and a small improvement on one might
actually unlock really big improvements on the other.
So basically, it's a great function of the space right now that we
can push on all of them, but it also means that there's not any one of those that's
more important than the other.
I see.
Okay.
Did you have another question?
Yeah. The other question is, do you think incorporating physics-based modeling
is important?
Yes. I was putting that in that filter category as well.
That's one of the pieces that is over here.
I think frankly,
if you just look at the
base model performance, things that are AI-based have been moving faster than the
physics-based.
Mm-hmm.
But as the models get better, then there's more opportunity to incorporate some of
the physics, for instance. So if your protein folding model gives you a bunch of
spaghetti, there's no physics to do.
But now if you have atomic resolution for your predictions, then you can
actually start to study what the structure looks like and learn something from it.
And that could be as simple as an antibody engineer looking at this and saying,
"Did I hit the right epitope?" Or something as sophisticated as a physics model
running some simulation to figure out what's going on.
So again, it's all these things coming together.
I see. Thanks for the answers.
Okay.
So let me draw this to a conclusion. Oh, hang on.
One last question. Okay, we got one more minute.
Just wonder, are you using AlphaFold 3 for drug design at this point?
Well,
I think in terms of the different iterations of
AlphaFold have informed some of the
internal modeling, but I don't think it's just sufficient on
its own, is what I would say we're currently at. Yeah.
Yeah, I think it's just one piece of the puzzle, like I was saying
before, for our work, for instance. We actually don't use AlphaFold.
AlphaFold 3 can't even be used by companies.
It's also fairly outdated at this point, at least from our perspective.
Like the model came out like a year and a half ago or two years
ago. And the models we have internally at Chai are way beyond that right
now. But some variant of that, like a protein folding model is a key part
of the workflow.
Yes. Yeah. I think that's what
we're both showing really. You start with that, but then it's iterated
and built, and then you can build your own version.
It's a bit like I was saying, there's the fine-tuning of the large data sets that
you've got will take you beyond that currently.
Right. Amo.
So with all the advances and all the knowledge and information you're putting into
developing these new drugs, which has high confidence, you take them to the
labs where you have to do all this plethora of tests and everything to make them
progress through the clinics. What are your thoughts and approaches,
if you are already implementing them, in evolving or
improving these analytical methods and tests to
make sure that you're actually getting the right drugs moving forward?
Because there's a whole lot of things and efforts done to develop these very great
drug candidates. Then how do you test them? How do you evolve them?
Because you have very traditional tests such as Western blotting to very elegant
3D models. So how are you inputting all these AI learnings and models
to develop these better tests?
Yeah, no, I think that's a really great question.
And it's a form of the benchmarking challenge
that you have with the large language model.
What question, what bar are you setting against it?
I still think that you're going to end up using some of the same
assays that we've currently got. But I also think that,
I don't know if you heard Bo Wang's talk from
Zyera this morning.
But he was giving one example of a cell-based model
where there's an input- Oops, sorry.
An input of
very large data set of very many different cell types across the body.
And you're looking at aspects of morphology
and phenotype as a core piece for going that.
I think that will be really informative
in terms of
better understanding the cellular context that you've
then got the drugs to work on. And I think this is just an example of how we're
going to need foundation models in multiple different mentions.
You got the foundation models for predicting what the biologic structure is for
the small molecule prediction. But I think you're also going to need foundation
models for looking at the biological output sets, which will
include
phenotype. And there's been this long debate about
phenotypic screening versus
individual target-based screening.
I think the cell-based foundation models will help us move and actually
incorporate phenotype knowledge sets into it,
because watching cells grow and the
shape and the dynamics of that, actually,
there's a lot of embedding of things that we don't necessarily have the
current assays for, information inherent in that,
that we are not paying attention to at the moment.
And I think that will be a really important puzzle. It's a great question.
Thank you.
So with that, thank you very much to Sagal and Josh
for your contribution. Thank you to all of you for staying to the end.
It's late now. I think it's time we
headed to either get food or drink, some variety of each. I know that I need one.
Thank you very much for your time and attention. Thank you.
Thank you.
Thank
you.